oh my god this is funny like
funny very funny
funny too
now that was kind of funny she got that
water splash drip
splash usman taking kim as a joke caused
him to get a little wet and from the
looks of it their short-lived
relationship as a couple and as friends
is over
do you think my friends want me here
self-light
yeah cool
i lost
and i'll probably never do it again ever
girl don't say that let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa before
we get into kim and usman i have to know
have y'all seen the teaser for the
upcoming season of 90 day fiance ari and
benny are back
i'm not going to marry you guys i'm
marrying vinya and his sister wish
better count her lucky stars that ari is
not about their life
wish literally threw red wine
red wine
in ari's face all right you go in there
start swinging
i cannot wait to get into that episode
with y'all plus
there is a lot of eye candy i was like
oh
oh
casting was definitely on point with
looks let's just make sure they're
checking old social media posts too
yes i have seen the headlines about mike
making racist and transphobic comments
on instagram i'm not sure what's going
on this season it seems like the people
we start rooting for
alina
are just going to disappoint us
by the way despite his friend's advice
mike didn't end the relationship with
ximena what a shocker when he tried to
break up with her she told him she
wanted to work things out
and they actually ended up getting
intimate that night
guess who got lucky
but after he got lucky she told him she
didn't want to sleep in the same bed
with him
until they're married so he's confused
again
i thought we were
taking like two steps forward
but then in reality it's really just
five cents backwards
look
i'm with mita who said this last week if
mike does not leave i will not feel
sorry for him anymore
i get that this is his first serious
relationship and it can make you dumb in
love but that on top of his alleged
social media post
i'm over it
and next week it looks like ximena is
going to say something that has him
running for the hills
you know what
i'm done
my mind's going crazy
all right let's get into what you came
here for
kim and osman
quick refresh after usman decided that
kim was officially his girlfriend
unfortunately
for his girlfriend
he then decided to finally come clean
and tell kim that his song zara
is about his ex i tell you everything
how dare you keep a secret for me
seriously when he previously told her
it's the name he picked out for all the
women across the world yeah but that's a
good lie where's the car
kim was pissed and embarrassed that she
came to tanzania for the song's music
video shoot and it clicked to her that
while usman was busy trying to create a
storyline for tv i loved being on tv he
left her in the dark looking
while she has been nothing but
supportive and loyal to him i feel
stupid i feel stupid i even came down
here and beside the song being about his
ex what kim seems to be mainly upset
about is that she had no clue usman was
in a full-blown relationship while they
were talking i would have never ever
ever in a million years
tried to pursue somebody that was in a
relationship i was cheated on and i
would never do that to anybody else for
all the time i've been talking to you
i'm not in love or relationship with you
you are my friend
meanwhile usman's argument is that he
didn't have to tell kim because she
wasn't his girlfriend
which brings us to this episode
kim is disappointed and emotionally
drained as she talks to her friend from
home and i'm like so down on myself now
you know
and it's not fair to me because i'm so
down on myself and i was i had so much
confidence when i got here
and everything and now it's just like
it's just gone but she comes to the
conclusion that she's going to give us
men one more chance to prove himself
before she packs her bags to leave he's
got to do something like romantic and
big and prove to me that he loves me
if usman doesn't prove this to me this
time i'm going to be so hurt all i could
think was kim you are setting yourself
up for disappointment again
why do we do that to ourselves when
someone is not behaving in the way we
want them to we still create these
expectations in our heads
when in reality they're already showing
us who they are and how they move we
just don't want to accept it
i think in kim's case she's going to
have to take her heart back from usman
she's given him way too much power over
how she feels about herself and quite
frankly he doesn't deserve it
looking cute today
thank you everyday
every day every day you look good
seriously
fast forward to their meet up on the
beach usman says he's going to stay calm
to show kim he wants to work things out
but once she starts to let him know how
she feels things escalate quickly
why would you bring me down here to have
shoot a video about another woman i feel
like this whole trip was very very
deceptive kim ben tells him to take off
his gold soulja boy chain that she
bought him on his birthday
i just want to see it and looking back
now this was such a smooth move on her
part do you know how much work this took
to get me this made i don't know i had
to i had to like go online find a place
i did it
it was sent i know how much you let me
finish
it was sent overseas i get it back paid
extra i paid like i think it was like 45
to get it sent to me like two days later
so you'd have it on your birthday that's
thought how much thought did you put in
this trip for me
nothing
oh
my heart dropped for her that's tough to
hear but to come to usman's defense it's
not his fault that she's willing to go
above and beyond for him i love that she
has a big heart but it can be a
double-edged sword because everyone
can't love like you do i didn't force
you to come mm-hmm
so what i'm saying i want you to know
the effort and the thought that i put
into this
i just don't feel like the love is there
also
one thing i've learned is that when most
men say how things are in regards to a
relationship that's how things are
usman said they were friends so he was
acting like a friend kim was acting like
a wife when no one told her to do that
this is no shade to kim i mean i'm a
victim of fairy tale expectations too
but the truth is when you get
disappointed
you can't blame anybody else but
yourself
when people
show you who they are believe them yes
hashtag preach in order for me to stay
here tonight
and not go home because there are
flights
you need to do something big kim also
tells us men until he proves his love
she'll be holding on to that chain
told you smooth move when you prove it
to me then you give it back i'm not
giving it oh my god this is funny oh
like
funny
very funny
funny too
i hope that was funny too
and she's off
kim tells the camera she has never
thrown a drink in anybody's face before
really
but usman triggered her and reminded her
of her ex-husband
my ex-husband would come home with
lipstick on his shirt and phone numbers
in his pocket and i would find them and
he'd be like hahaha kim like you don't
know what you're talking about
you're so funny when you're mad and a
complete disregard for my feelings and i
will not put up with that again
while kim was having flashbacks usman
was feeling totally disrespected i don't
know if it is normal in america
but in my region and the world i know it
is
highly disrespect
and i will not stand for it they
continue to argue in her hotel room
which every time they're in there i
can't help but think about how much she
is paying for that honeymoon suite yet
dealing with all this drama
but
that's beside the point either you come
correct with me and prove it i'm getting
on a plane tonight when kim threatened
to leave for good
what usman told her next
broke my heart so i can only imagine how
she felt and don't think i won't do it
do not think i won't do it you think my
friends want me here self light what did
you say you think my friends want me
here
safe light
when you get there
cool
cool i will book it tonight
breathe girl
breathe
usman says safe flight
in a moment like this you want your man
to fight for you and
he's just letting it go
considering the way kim was feeling
about herself earlier i know this has
her thinking
am i not worth it
apparently the relationship is done very
good good
that was kind of a joke but
not really
so honestly i'm not feeling the
relationship anymore right now with
kimberly usman says kim now reminds him
of his ex-wife lisa
all the while kim is breaking down in
tears
i'm so angry right now i could just
break everything in this room he said
have a safe flight that was all the
answer i needed
so
that's it
it's going to be very very hard to
remove usman from my life because he's
been such a party it's not just like
he's a little part of my life like he's
a it's a 24-hour thing you know what i
mean and i've gotten so used to him
calling me every morning or me calling
him the texting everything is so much i
can't even think about it it's gonna be
really hard and i'll probably never do
it again ever
kim has been through a lot in love but
i'll be darned if she allows her
ex-husband and usemen to stop her from
finding the real thing she might be a
little worn out right now which is
understandable but hopefully she doesn't
give up and for all we know based off
the teaser
her and usman might get back together
next week he just texted me and told me
to meet him at the beach bar
i'm leery
i know it's over like i know it's over
but i mean it could be a mind game
oh no
he said no i'm shaking
stay in your power girl stay in your
power
oh i'm actually speaking to kim soon so
y'all know the deal
drop any questions you may have for
kimbally in the comments and i'll pick a
few all right 90 day fans fam make sure
you stick with et because we are
covering it all i will see you next time
[Music]